tijuana the border city that's become an
epicenter of mexico's rocketing number
of press attacks
two journalists were killed here in just
one week
jose luis gamboa this is the sound of
their colleagues in mourning
martinez's murders are still under
investigation and constantly in the mind
of local reporters
like anna lilia ramirez she's just
making her first cup of coffee when her
editor sent her a video of this
morning's presidential press conference
but after watching she says the
authorities are no closer to solving
them and i feel bad
because they are my friend
and i feel bad
i'm sorry
i think uh the people that yell
is not it's only like kill it the man
yeah not the ones who planned it and
mastermind it yeah
around 95 of journalist murders in
mexico go unsolved and that's been the
case for years but the current
administration has also seen an almost
85 percent jump in crimes against the
press say free speech advocates with
seven reporters killed so far this year
what do you think the attitude of
president lopez obrador is to this what
is his attitude
that we're crazy he thinks anybody who
says hey they're killing us is part of
the opposition
when lopez obrador came to tijuana to
speak to the press corps just after
their colleagues had been killed he took
the opportunity to criticize journalists
he often does
these famous journalists who are for
hire we should find out how much they
earn because they get a lot of money
they're mercenaries
with an apparent lack of official
support journalists here band together
to protect each other as we ride with
anna lilia to her first assignment
messages ping in
[Music]
from a reporters what's up group they've
set up
this one from a colleague on the same
day pulls us both up short
he's assaulted right next to the police
in the middle of a protest
so it just seems constant in this chat
between journalists here um the tension
um
and the threats and that something could
possibly happen
less than two months ago anna lilia
tells me she had her own close shave
after reporting on femicides an armed
man followed her while on the road and
into a shopping center
his bag was open i looked in and saw a
gun in there the only thing i was
thinking in the shop was i might die
here my colleagues had just been killed
she asked the army to rescue her these
photos are taken from when they came and
got her
it was then she entered mexico's press
protection program but while some
journalists say it saved them others
like ana lilia say they've got no help
after the ceremony she's been sent to
cover she takes a chance to ask the
police state commissioner about that
some people say that they just get a
message others just a photo rather than
the police patrols at their house no
[Music]
but in mexico the threats could come
from anywhere not just narcos police
even politicians
and at risk
not only journalists but the chance to
challenge power or provide a voice for
those without one
john holman al jazeera tijuana